Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen, Liebe. Guten Morgen, Tim.
Ausgabe Nummer siebenundzwanzig von Logbuch Netzpolitik. Der Podcast, der versucht, Keimdetail äh zu wenig Aufmerksamkeit zu schenken. Na ja,
Äh was war denn das für eine Woche? Nichts besonders Aufregendes, würde ich sagen, oder?
Nee, nix besonders aufregendes, aber trotzdem natürlich sehr äh interessante äh Sachen,
äh gestern am sechsten Juni war mal wieder IP V sechs Tag,
Ja, ich glaube, es gab schon mal einen. Also sie versuchen das ja irgendwie seit seit Jahren. Es gab äh glaube ich vor ein, zwei Jahren schon mal irgendwie so, ne, heute ist aber alles mal IP V sechs oder so.
Ähm so ein bisschen wie Vogel des Jahres, ne, es nimmt auch keiner so richtig warm, wa?
Ja, also ähm,
Das war vor allem, betraf das, also ich meine, Google bietet, glaube ich, sowieso seine Service, das ist schon so unter IP V sechs an, aber irgendwie die großen äh äh Content des Revision Networks irgendwie AKMI und so. Die mussten halt nochmal
noch nicht so angeboten,
und ähm Telekom aber übrigens auch noch nicht so wirklich. Ähm aber um das vielleicht erstmal zu erklären, was ist denn überhaupt IFIV sechs? Ähm,
Wir haben ja momentan das, also das Internet hat ja ein Protokoll unter dem Internet liegt quasi das IP-Protokoll,
seine Internetadresse hat und was heute genutzt wird, ist IP V vier,
und das besteht, das sind diese Adressen, die sie irgendwie aus den hundertsiebenundsiebzig Punkt hundertachtundzwanzig Punkt neunzehn Punkt fünf oder so ist dann eine IP-Adresse und ähm davon gibt es,
Warte mal, ich muss kurz überlegen. Zwei hoch zweiunddreißig. Einen im Sinn. Äh vier Milliarden zweihundert
vierundneunzig Millionen neunhundertsiebenundsechzigtausendzweihundertsechsundfünfzig, glaube ich, ja, wenn ich mich jetzt nicht vertan habe.
Knapp dran.
Er war richtig, oder?
Bis auf ein Zehntel, ja.
Ja, so und äh so viele, so viele IP-Adressen gibt's. Und also im V vier Bereich und die neigen sich jetzt langsam dem Ende zu. Und das liegt,
Einerseits daran, dass es wahrscheinlich wirklich annähernd so viele ans Internet verbundene Geräte gibt. Und vor allem daran, dass ähm.
Diese diese Blöcke, also das sind diese vier Blöcke A äh zweihundert äh sechsundfünfzig Möglichkeiten und.
Also wenn man jetzt so die die ersten drei nimmt, dann bleiben da hinterher zweihundertsechsundfünfzig Adressen, die ich vergeben kann. Wenn ich aber jetzt zweihundertsiebenundfünfzig habe, dann brauche ich quasi zwei,
zwei Blöcke von dem dritten Teil, also von mir aus die neunzehn und die achtzehn und blockiere damit automatisch äh fünfhundertzwölf mögliche IP-Adressen.
Ja? Und ähm das heißt oder wenn ich und also wenn ich jetzt hier diesen Teil nehme so, dann habe ich halt ähm ja, also.
Jetzt kommen wir hier in so ein Technik-Podcast rein, um's einfach zu machen.
Digga, danke, ganz kurz, ich bin ja, ich bin ja gleich fertig. Also einfach zu machen, die gehen dem gehen dem Ende zu. Ja. Und und jetzt kommt der, jetzt kommt der spannende Teil, warum interessiert das überhaupt jemanden? Und ähm,
Der Grund dafür war oder der Grund ist, weil von vorneherein klar war, dass man eigentlich nicht genug IP V4-Adressen hat, um jedem Gerät eine feste zu geben. Ähm,
haben die Provider damals, als es irgendwie mit Dial-Up irgendwie losging, du kommst ins Internet,
haben sie damals dynamisch IP-Adressen vergeben. Das heißt, jemand, der sich ins Internet eingewählt hat und ist auch heute noch so, bekommt eigentlich jedes Mal eine andere IP,
die wechselt sich. Ähm das war eigentlich eher könnte man sagen, so eine Art zufällig,
zufällige äh Entscheidung, so eine Art ähm Anonymity bei Excellent, ja, das war jetzt nicht irgendwie großartig, es gab keinen ähm,
Keinen anderen Grund, das zu machen, ja. Es war einfach nur, es war klar, machen wir mal dynamisch, so.
Jetzt wählt sich irgendwie jeder immer ins Internet rein und auch wenn man einen DSL-Anschluss hat, wird man einmal in vierundzwanzig Stunden getrennt und kriegt eine neue IP und das hat ja eigentlich den hat halt diese Vorteile, dass man eben keine IP hat, die einem fest zugewiesen ist, wie so eine Art,
Kennzeichen. Hat aber den Nachteil, dass man, wenn man irgendwie nach Hause telefonieren möchte, übers Internet ähm in der Regel nach einem Tag seine IP nicht mehr weiß, unter der man seinen Rechner erreicht, ja? Und dann irgendwie oft dünn DNS-Dienst oder sowas geben muss. So und jetzt ähm.
Wenn man sie überhaupt wusste.
Genau, wenn man sie überhaupt jemals wusste. So und jetzt ähm heißt es also quasi der Datenschützer sagt ähm ja, das ist sehr gut, dass die IP-Adressen
sich ändern, weil wir sind ja trotzdem identifizierbar, wenn man irgendwie nicht mit meiner IP-Adresse Quatsch mache, kann ja trotzdem jemand beim Provider anrufen und fragen, wertet zu der und der Uhrzeit dieser IP-Adresse? Und dann sagen die, das war der und der,
aber es ist nicht irgendwie so, dass dass man jemanden einmal identifiziert und der behält diese IP-Adresse sein Leben lang, so wie jetzt irgendwie ein Server.
Und da ist genau der Nachteil, weil man kann eigentlich ohne weitere Tricksereien zu Hause keine Server betreiben, weil die IP-Adresse sich andauernd ändert.
Wie gesagt, man kann dann über Dünn DNS oder sowas irgendwie umbiegen. So, aber jetzt sind also diese IP- äh vier Adressen sind aufgebraucht. Wir haben also quasi,
Und ähm,
Ähm.
Jetzt, jetzt muss also IP V sechs her versuchen, vielleicht noch ganz kurz, was was noch äh so ein bisschen erklärt werden muss, ist wie der, wie damit umgegangen wird, dass wir heute eigentlich nicht mehr genug IP-Adressen haben, ist halt dieses äh,
Also Network at Restferndl, wo also die Fritzbox zu Hause, die hat eine IP
mit dem Internet Provider verbunden ist und vergibt dann wieder neue IPs innerhalb des des WLANs, in dem ihr euch dann befindet und nach draußen sieht aber alles wie ein Anschluss aus.
Was dann auch wieder eine Schwierigkeit ist, wenn man nämlich jetzt zum Beispiel sagt, man möchte zu Hause einen Server betreiben, dann muss die Fritzbox irgendwie in die Porz durchroden und so weiter. Also alles nicht so einfach. Mit IP V sechs
haben wir nicht mehr zweiunddreißig Bitadressen, sondern hundertachtundzwanzig Bit Adressen,
Also acht, sechzehn Bitblöcke, glaube ich, wenn ich die enttäusche und das ist dann, also die Anzahl an Adressen, die dabei rauskommt, ist eine drei mit achtunddreißig Nullen.
Hinter.
Das zähle ich jetzt nicht nach.
Das sind sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr viele. Also man.
Es ist einfach eine verdammt irre große Zahl.
Verdammt irre große Zahl und es ist in nächst in näherer Zeit jetzt nicht damit zu rechnen, dass dass es keine IP V sechs Adressen mehr gibt. Und die besteht vom ersten Teil aus dem Netzanteil.
Also nicht nur nicht in näherer Zeit, sondern auf absehbare Zeit.
Nibla hat äh beim Abend gesagt mal gucken, vielleicht setzt sich das mit dem Internet ja auch gar nicht durch. Ja, also vielleicht ist das sowieso.
Das ist natürlich denkbar.
Ähm so und jetzt hast du bei den IP for sechs hast du eben so, das sind so durch Doppelpunkte getrennte äh Viererblöcke und da hast du vorne den Netzanteil,
Wie bei den, bei den IPV vier auch und hinten den Hostanteil. Und jetzt war es ursprünglich so, dass dieser dieser Hostanteil, der wird quasi von deinem, für deinen Rechner generiert und im ursprünglichen Vorschlag war das so, dass der sich aus der MAC-Adresse erstellt. Und das hätte.
Der physikalischen Adresse deiner Computer, Schnittstelle, Isanette oder WLAN et cetera die werkseitig zugewiesen ist.
Werkseitig zugewiesen ist und ebenfalls einzigartig. Unter wenn, also unter wenn man jetzt nicht irgendwie mit achtziger Jahre Hardware vergleicht oder so, aber eigentlich eine die MAC-Adresse einer Netzwerkkarte ist nicht irgendwo doppelt.
Sollte sie zumindest nicht sein.
Nicht sein. Und ähm das hieße also, du hättest quasi in dem Hausteil eine,
Eindeutig zuweisbare Adresse für jedes Gerät und die bleibt würde dann auch gleich bei deinem, egal in welchem Netz du bist, das heißt,
durch diese feste Adresse bin ich jetzt hier bei dir, geht mein mein iPad was hier liegt irgendwie ins Internet und man würde allein an dem Hausteil schon erkennen,
dass ich das bin. Und an dem Netzteil könnte man erkennen.
Welche Weg du grade.
Wo ich gerade bin, ja?
Wurde dann irgendwann geändert durch die Privacy Extension, dass dieser Hausteil einfach irgendwie äh äh zufällig zugewiesen und irgendwie äh Nigos wird. Und für den Netzteil, der vorne dran ist, der wird eben vom ISP zugewiesen.
Und ähm,
Da ist jetzt quasi der der Lobbyismus im Gange, dass man den ISPs, die ISPs dazu bringen will, muss, ähm dass sie diesen Netzteil trotzdem dynamisch zuteilen.
Obwohl es nicht mehr notwendig ist,
Also sie könnten wirklich einfach jedem äh was haben wir dann? Das sind dann äh vierundsechzig Bit, also damit könntest du äh erstmal einen Großteil der der Internetanschlüsse,
Äh so versorgen. Und du hast ja den Hausteil nochmal dahinter. Das heißt, da ist also ist da quasi schon so ungefähr mit mit mit,
erledigt, brauchst du halt nicht mehr, ne.
Und ähm da ist jetzt gerade also die die der Lobbyismus und der Datenschutzaktivismus richtet so sich so in diese Richtung, dass man das, dass man sagt, okay, die ISP sollen bitte die Dinger dynamisch vergeben. Und dann gibt's natürlich viele Leute, die irgendwie sagen, sie sie möchten jetzt irgendwie Dienste zu Hause betreiben,
die sagen, nee, bloß nicht, endlich können können wir alle eine feste IP haben,
Ähm das war ja früher quasi oder ist auch heute noch eigentlich ein Dienst, für den man bezahlen muss, wenn man eine Fest-IP haben möchte und sagen, wir wollen das jetzt endlich,
Äh äh so so geklärt haben. Fakt ist, wenn man das jetzt so umsetzt, wie es momentan geplant ist, dann ähm habt ihr eine feste,
Anschlusskennung und wenn ihr nicht irgendwie euer Betriebssystem noch ummodelt auf die Privacy Extension, die bei den meisten dann doch nicht automatisch aktiviert ist. Ähm ein festes Kennzeichen an jedem eurer Geräte.
Also meines Wissens ist das sehr wohl implementiert mit diesen.
Ist implementiert, aber nicht aktiviert. Also muss bei den meisten äh bei den meisten äh Betriebssystemen dann nochmal irgendwo ein Häkchen setzen oder so.
Aber diese diese feste Mac-Adresse, die wird auch sozusagen nur verwendet, wenn du lokal,
selbst eine Adresse zuweist, also sozusagen so diese Autokonfiguration in dem Moment, wo du wirklich eine IP for sechs Connectivity hast und dein Provider sagt, hier IPhone sechs nimm mal teil, dann kriegst du ja.
Genau dann würdest du nämlich unter unter normaler Spezifikation genau deine Meckadresse nehmen, weil das die einfachste Möglichkeit ist sicherzustellen, dass du den Provider gegenüber eine Adresse hast, die ähm die er mich nicht mit irgendwelchen anderen Nigoshielten muss.
Und das ist ja der der Horst Anteil. Also du hast das quasi nur dein, also das auf dich bezogen ist nur der die hinteren vier Blöcke,
Und vom vom Provider vorgegeben sind die die Forderung vier.
Ja und jetzt.
Na ja, also so lobbyieren, lobbyieren Freunde, so. Jetzt Druck machen, dass dass wir ähm möglichst äh dynamische Netzanteile in unserem IP V sechs bekommen. Ja.
Also laut Wikipedia heißt es hier.
Okay, okay, das, das, das.
Und iOS. Einen Worten,
Es ist jetzt schon eigentlich gar kein Problem mehr. Doch. Außer bei Linox.
Nee, das ist ja dasselbe genau also diese private Extensions lösen ja nur die Hälfte des Problems. Nämlich den Host Anteil. Die Privacy Extensions lösen
Im Zweifelsfall, dass ich, wenn ich bei dir bin, nicht als der Linus identifizierbar bin, der vorher bei sich war.
Aber ähm der Netzanteil, also die vorderen vier Blöcke, die die dir jetzt hier von deinem äh von deinem Provider zugeteilt werden, wenn die halt immer gleich blieben, dann gäbe es quasi den,
Einmal identifizierten Meterebene Anschluss und da wüsste jeder, wo äh oder könnte jeder halt,
sich merken, was das ist. Das heißt, ähm die Hälfte des Problems ist gelöst, nämlich die, dass wir uns bewegen können in anderen Netze,
und der hat hoffentlich nicht wieder identifizierbar sind,
Aber dass einzelne Anschlüsse, feste festzugewiesenen Netzanteile haben, ähm das Problem ist eben noch nicht gelöst.
So man es als.
Aber es ist, aber es ist lösbar.
Da wird man sehen, also äh wird sich zeigen, ob die Provider da Lust drauf haben, das zu machen. Also es, es gibt, wie gesagt, es gibt halt auch ein Interesse daran, ähm,
Das wirklich.
Durchaus trägbar zu machen.
Genau, dass du da und auch dafür zu sorgen, dass halt dass du einfach du könntest halt wirklich dafür sorgen, dass du eine feste IP V sechs Adresse hast, Punkt.
Und dann kann halt jeder auch einen Dienst anbieten. Das heißt, jeder ist halt einfach unter einer festen IP erreichbar.
Problem ist allerdings dann auch, dass dass du nicht mehr so was so Standard in brauchst und deswegen wahrscheinlich auch nicht mehr machst. Und das natürlich ähm,
Hm, sagen wir mal diese diese Billo Firewalls, die irgendwie in jedem in jedem äh Router mit drin sind. Die im Zweifelsfall nicht mehr so greifen würden oder so.
Naja, also das Thema wird sich auf jeden Fall kräftig aufheizen. Äh die Telekom hat, glaube ich, zum Ende dieses Jahres. Äh IP V sechs Connectivity für alle Anschlüsse oder zumindest für manche Anschlüsse, ich weiß nicht, haben sie von allen gesprochen, aber ich,
mal über kurz oder lang ähm wird sich das dann komplett ausrollen,
Mit allen Worten ähm wer heute schon mit sechs kompatiblen Gerät an diesen DSL-Anschlüssen dran ist, der wird dann eben auch auf einmal so es nicht ausgeschaltet wurde in der Konfiguration, sechs haben, also alles, was,
Fritz also alle neueren Rauter, die jetzt nicht schon seit sechs Jahren zu Hause stehen, die,
Werden ähm mit einer gewissen Wahrscheinlichkeit auch dann automatisch,
mitspielen und neuere Betriebssysteme sind eben auch alle ab Werk schon mit ausgerüstet das heißt man wird häufiger schon mit V sechs auf 'ne Webseite geraten, ohne dass man das groß merkt, weil für den User ist das ja alles das.
Ich war mir ganz sicher, merkt man das tatsächlich nicht? Also ich glaube bei Google zum Beispiel bei den meisten Testinstanzen habe ich immer irgendwie gesehen, dass man noch IP V sechs angeben musste, also den VIP V sechs Punkt Google Punkt com oder so, also.
Die Frage ist, wie dein Betriebssystem fragt, wenn du halt eine Domain äh eingibst und das Betriebssystem ist der Meinung, das bist du jetzt erstmal nach der V sechs Adresse fragen und wenn da eine kommt, dann connectet er halt dahin.
Ah okay, alles klar, ja.
Ne
äh das ist eher eine Frage, wie die ja die Strategien sind. Da gab's auch im Detail noch einige Probleme. Das überblicke ich gerade nicht so richtig wieder. Der aktuelle Stand ist. Aber,
So oder so, also man muss einfach damit rechnen, dass das eben stattfindet und deswegen sollte man sich eben auch bei Gelegenheit mal so mit den Firewall-Realitäten seines äh ähm Heimnetzes auseinandersetzen, was IPV sechs betrifft.
Also, wie gesagt, aber diese Umstellung ist wirklich etwas, was so bisschen das das Ding wie Internet irgendwie heute erlebt wird. Ähm durchaus so ein bisschen ähm,
Auf jeden Fall da ein paar äh Rahmenbedingungen halt ändern kann, ne, wo also wirklich.
Genau, es wird nämlich alles toller und bunter.
Das würde aber auch ohne IPV sechs passieren.
Echt toller, ohne IPV sechs. Mensch.
So, was die Zukunftskompaktivität betrifft, gibt es auch bei der Bundeswehr äh neue Bewegungen.
Die Bundeswehr kann jetzt Cyberwall.
Das heißt, sie haben sich jetzt eine äh eine Side White Installation von äh.
Ich dachte eher so von dem aktuellen äh kommen lassen.
Eigentlich, ja das stimmt, das so ah, das wäre echt geil irgendwie, so wie wie war das irgendwie äh früher war doch dann auch so diese so diese Schlachten, wo man sich dann auf der Wiese getroffen hat, sieht man in so alten Filmen, dann schneiden die sich alle gegenüber, haben gefeuert und dann irgendwie so, dann wurde halt dieser Krieg an dieser Stelle oder diese Schlacht an dieser Stelle entschieden, ne,
Das könnte man ja auch dann so mit Counter-Strike oder so machen so. Wir fordern sie heraus zum,
ähm fünfzehn Uhr mitteleuropäische Zeit.
Cyber Battle auf History. Genau und da äh stehen sich dann die entsprechenden Bundeswehrsoldaten gegenüber mit den äh,
Bösen, was sind die aktuellen Bösen grade.
Teamred weiß ich nicht.
Salafisten oder so, keine Ahnung, was auch immer gerade so der Feind, das Feindbild äh äh der Woche ist,
Ja, aber äh wir reden natürlich Quatsch und die Wahrheit ist, es gibt jetzt ein Cyber War ähm tja, Fokus in der Bundeswehr, wie sieht der denn aus?
Es gibt das Kommando, strategische Aufklärung und ähm das Kommando strategische Aufklärung.
Ist nicht verbannt, verwandt mit diesen ähm,
Äh mit den, sage ich mal, defensiven äh IT-Kräften der Bundeswehr,
sondern die sind also wirklich ähm zum auch im Angreifen geschult, ja? Und äh wurden hauptsächlich äh rekrutiert von den ähm Bundeswehruniversitäten.
Ja, wo sie irgendwie Informatik studiert haben. Das heißt, diesen Bundeswehr-Hackern scheint also schon mal eine Schlüsselqualifikation zu fehlen. Nämlich das abgebrochene Informatikstudium. Das braucht man ja eigentlich.
Das braucht man ja eigentlich. Ja, das stimmt.
Und äh das haben sie also schon mal nicht, ja? Sie haben ein abgeschlossenes wehrlos, ja. Und also genau, so und die sind also jetzt haben eine eine Art Grundausbildung, der ähm.
Des Angreifens und irgendwo unter Laborbedingungen, ne, also irgendwie, weiß ich nicht, irgendeinen Laden dann gemacht und irgendwie gelernt, äh wie man wie man äh wie man da jetzt hackt. Und äh ähm.
Meine Herren präsentiert den Pottscanner. Christoph.
Ja, also äh äh es ist auf jeden Fall die die Anzahl der Mitarbeiter ist erstmal unbekannt, sie sind getrennt von dieser Abwehrabteilung und ähm ja, wollen irgendwie jetzt wohl strategische ähm,
Cyber-Work-Führung irgendwie einander betreiben. Jetzt ist natürlich ganz interessant so was ähm was was kennzeichnet eigentlich so ein so ein Cyber-Ohr? Also ähm,
in Vergleich zu, sagen wir mal so, so einen Panzer oder oder,
Luftangriff auf auf irgendwie eine Stadt ähm hat man natürlich wahrscheinlich geringere Kosten, wenn man einfach jetzt mal irgendwie so versucht da was zu hacken,
Man hat eigentlich auch ein trotzdem noch ein sehr großes äh Schadenspotenzial,
Also ist trotz ist jetzt nicht irgendwie kostenlos, aber ist wahrscheinlich im Vergleich zu zu so zu irgendwie so einem Leopard äh sonst was, die wir ja gerade nach Saudi Arabien verkaufen, das ist irgendwie so ein Hack, wahrscheinlich etwas günstiger. Und ähm.
Du hast äh also es gibt quasi so eine ähm so Theorie Theorien darüber, dass das jetzt quasi auch so den den David äh also die kleineren Staaten und die Terroristen irgendwie ermutigt sich in in dieser asymmetrischen Kriegsführung irgendwie zu ähm,
betätigen, ja? Und ähm du hast ähm,
Vor allem so ein Nachweisbarkeitsding, ja? Also ähm es ist, muss nicht unbedingt nachweisbar sein, dass du diesen Angriff,
gefahren hast. Das heißt, du ermutigt eigentlich zu so einer Art Kriegsführung, so einerseits mit größerer Aggressivität,
und äh vielleicht auch so so Täuschungen und so, ne. Also du hast eher, du hast eher Mut, den den Erstschlag zu machen, ja. Ähm wie gesagt, so der erste weltweit bekannte äh Cyber War, Erstschlag war ja war ja so dieses Stucksnett,
Virus, was was äh,
sehr gezielt auf Siemens, Ventile, die in der Anreicherung von Uran äh angewendet wurden, ähm,
abgesetzt war und eigentlich letztendlich zum Ziel hatte, irgendwie dieser Urananreicherungsanlagen im Iran irgendwie zu infizieren und dort irgendwie.
Zerstören oder oder an ihrer Arbeit zu hindern. Es hat, glaube ich, auch ganz gut geklappt. Es war auf jeden Fall high level äh,
Im Moment gibt's wieder so ein Ding, Flame heißt das, das äh auch eine äh also sehr interessanten Infektionswicht gefunden hat. Ähm und das Ding ist ja bei beiden war so,
Selbst bei Stucks net, jetzt gibt's grade irgendwie die die die Theorie, dass Obama das selber angeordnet hätte mit diesem Stück, selber so, es gibt immer noch keine vernünftige
Nachweisbarkeit von von höchster Ebene, was man jetzt in die Geschichtsbücher schreiben muss, wer wer war das mit Stucks net? Ähm und das heißt,
Dieser Cyberwalk könnte also in eine ganz, ganz verrückte Welt nochmal führen. Ja, also so eine ganz andere Form der Kriegsführung. Und die Bundeswehr stellte sich natürlich dann auch sofort hin und sprach dann von von Stromnetzen und Wasserwerken, äh die sind natürlich,
nicht irgendwie am Internet, ja, unbedingt. Also und
aber OK mit haben wir auch gesehen dass man eben auch dann Dinge infizieren kann die die nicht ans Internet angeschlossen sind
und die die Bundeswehr will jetzt auf jeden Fall da mitmischen. Und jetzt stellt sich natürlich die Frage.
Und das ist eigentlich ganz witzig. Ähm was ist jetzt, ist das jetzt ein Krieg? Und ähm gilt dann der Parlamentsvorbehalt?
Also muss quasi, wenn die, wenn diese, wenn das äh Kommando strategische Aufklärung sagt, wir möchten jetzt gerne, was weiß ich, äh in,
mit wem haben wir gerade Knatsch,
was weiß ich, wir wir legen uns mit den Russen an, wollen wir denen irgendwas jetzt äh hacken, ja? Müssen die dann erstmal ins Parlament gehen und brauchen dann quasi den Parlamentsbeschluss, äh äh,
Deutsche.
Allem ist es ja eine Verteidigungsarmee, also ich meine äh Angriffsbefähigung.
Ist ja eigentlich hier nicht vorgesehen, ne.
Ja und aber so, dann meldeten sich auch schon irgendjemand von der SPD, sagte dann, ja, also ist ja auf jeden Fall kein rechtsfreier Raum mit diesem Internet,
Fand ich sehr interessant, weil was ist jetzt, was wäre jetzt, wenn sie so demnächst so ein so ein Internetvölkerrecht gibt äh bezüglich des Cyber Wars? Also weißt du, du darfst äh die Daten extrahieren, aber nicht löschen,
Weil ähm das verstößt gegen die gegen die Internet völkerrechtlichen Konventionen zum Cyberkrieg oder so. Das finde ich irgendwie.
Könnte ich mir durchaus vorstellen, dass sich sowas entwickelt. Ich meine, im Prinzip haben wir so was in Deutschland ja auch schon.
Hakaethik oder was?
Nee, nicht Hocker-Ethik, sondern hier schlicht der äh Beschluss des Bundesverfassungsgerichts äh in Reaktion auf die Klage gegen die Onlinedurchsuchung
die ja im Prinzip uns das äh ein Grundrecht eingeräumt hat, nämlich äh das mit diesem langen Titel, der Unversehrtheit, die sich der Unversehrtheit, der eigenen äh Infrastruktur.
Ja gut, aber es ist natürlich im Krieg äh kannst du natürlich so ein Urteil schlecht zur Anwendung bringen, ne.
Ich sage nur, im Geiste dessen, ja, also dass das äh äh man meint es ja, vielleicht gibt es ja in der Zukunft äh genauso könnte ich mir eine UNO
Konventionen vorstellen, ja, die so wie sie die Menschenrechte definiert, eben uns auch eine die Integrität unserer Informationstechnischen Systeme sicherstellt so, ne?
Und dann wäre dann sozusagen ein Angriff dagegen, dann eben wie das verletzen. Genau, ja, so.
Krieg.
Richtung wir lachen ja? Also ich,
wer nicht nur nicht überrascht, äh wenn sowas bald dann auch mal in die Debatte kommt. Ich meine in zwanzig Jahren,
Sind.
Sind die Leute, die heute, sagen wir mal so, als Netzaffine Anfänger in der Politik unterwegs sind, so diese dreißig hier, wir merken ja, wie unsere Generation jetzt langsam in diese Pöstchen,
zumindest in der zweiten Reihe reinwächst, ja? Also das werden jetzt so langsam die Zuarbeiter, die äh Fach,
Assistenten der Politiker bis hinzu dann irgendwann auch mal den Staatssekretären und äh mittelfristig eben auch die Ministerie,
ja? Und auch die Old Boys Network sind halt irgendwann auch schon mal mit einem C vierundsechzig groß geworden. Weltweit. Und das
Das wird seine Auswirkung haben. Ich denke, dass diese digitale Realität, über die man heute noch so ein bisschen schmunzeln kann, wenn sie so auf die äh Wahrscheinlich KF die,
trifft, irgendwann so normal sein wird, dass das einfach unumgänglich ist, dass wir äh das digitale Miteinander auch auf neue Beine stellen. Das ist
Das wird passieren. Muss passieren.
Also das, das, da bin, da will ich ja so soweit zustimmen. Ich frage mich nur, also jetzt ernsthaft, ich meine,
Es ist ganz klar, dass das auch Staaten hacken, ja, also ähm und dass das irgendwie auch andere Staaten sehr viel weiter wahrscheinlich sind, damit irgendwelche in Anführungszeichen Cyber-Armeen zu bilden, ja? Ähm,
Die Sache ist natürlich, wenn du sowas, wenn du sowas ernsthaft machen willst, dann ähm,
dann musst du das natürlich irgendwie so im Geheimdienstbereich eigentlich unterbringen und
irgendwelche Special Special oder sonst was äh und äh irgendwie außerhalb deiner eigenen Verfassung da agieren. Weil du kannst ja nicht, also ich meine, stelle, man stelle sich vor, ähm
in der Zeitung steht so ja ähm Bundeswehr hat heute Nacht äh ersten Angriff auf Afghanistan äh gestartet
die Seite der Regierung war mehrere Stunden aufgrund eines Tätos Angriffes nicht erreichbar, oder? Also wie,
so funktioniert ja Cyber-Work nicht. Der wird ja, der wird ja eigentlich nicht so öffentlich geführt. Also den willst du ja, du möchtest ja eigentlich eher mein.
Wieso? Ich meine, wenn's so wirklich um das äh meine wir sehen ja schon, das Ziel ist vor allem Infrastruktur. Das ist eigentlich das, was man halt so, ja? Und wenn die Bundeswehr dann mal den Strom ausschaltet,
und dann irgendwie äh äh die Früchte in der Klinik verrecken deswegen so, dann dann ist das halt eine Debatte.
Also ich will der Bundeswehr jetzt hier nichts unterstellen. Das war jetzt vielleicht ein bisschen hart formuliert, aber ich sage nur, wir wissen, dass,
solche Implikationen da kommen können, ja, ich meine, äh ob du nur eine Bombe aufn ähm Elektrizitätswerk wirfst oder ob du es elektronisch ausschaltest, so denn das möglich ist.
Am Ende keine Rolle, ja? Die Konsequenz dessen ist äh entscheidend so, ne.
Um Elektrizitätskraftwerk irgendwie außer Kraft zu setzen, brauchst du wirklich 'ne ganze Menge Bundeswehr, Hochschulabsolventen.
Ja, na ja gut, klar, aber dass das alles nicht ganz ist, das da sind wir uns sicherlich auch einig.
Es geht auf jeden Fall in die Richtung, dass solche, dass solche Dinge gemacht werden.
Werden irgendwann komplett elektronisch geregelte und haben das auch teilweise jetzt schon komplett also unser ganzes Energieversorgungsnetz,
elektronisch geregelt sein. Derzeit gibt's da noch sehr viel statisches und manuelles, aber würde kurz oder lang, sind allein die Anforderungen des Einsatzes regenerativer äh äh Energien, ja, überall wird
Da ist grad viel Wind, da wird Strom äh generiert, der muss dynamisch umgeleitet werden et cetera. Also das das Ganze
funktionierendes der Energieverteilung wird auf solchen Computertechnischen Prozessen basieren. Wenn du jetzt in der Lage bist, so eine Infrastruktur nachhaltig zu stören, dann kannst du da richtig,
Dinge zerstören. Ja, da,
äh äh kaputt. Da gehen Infrastrukturen kaputt, da gehen dann funktionieren Sachen nicht mehr, die eben auf die Zulieferung von Energie angewiesen sind et cetera PP. Also das wird tendenziell eher alles noch sehr viel fragiler. Insofern
vollkommen vertretbar,
wünschenswert, dass sagen wir mal auch eine Bundeswehr, sich eben mit dieser Fragestellung äh äh beschäftigt, wie kann man eben das verteidigen,
Ja, weniger aber, wie kann man jetzt die Netze der anderen Länder äh versenken?
In diesem Fall ist es also wirklich äh wie gesagt, die sind die sind das ist jetzt eine Angriffsgruppe, ne? Und klar bei bei wenn jetzt Cyberware ist, ja
dann dann reicht's ja nicht nur also eine Verteidigungsgruppe werden dann halt irgendwie Leute die versuchen diese Hacks abzuwehren und muss natürlich dann irgendwie auch Vergeltungsschlag machen ja? Und da brauchst du also irgendwie diese das Kommando strategische Aufklärung. Ähm.
Ich denke auch, dass es ohne Zweifel klar ist, dass diese, dass es zu etwas wie dem Cyber oder oder solchen Informationstechnischen Angriffen,
dass wir davon mehr sehen werden,
da bin, da bin ich mir ähm relativ sicher, auch in dem vielleicht in dem, also genau auf diese Infrastruktur, die du da ansprichst, äh,
abzielend. Ähm die Sache ist natürlich,
Das ist ja je also kritische Infrastruktur ist ja jedem klar und es ist halt nicht so, als wäre der Hauptsteuerungscomputer vom nächsten Atomkraftwerk äh mit einer IP V sechs Adresse ohne Firewall im Internet, ja? Ähm.
Zumindest immer wieder beteuert.
Hoffen, hoffen wir das.
Ne? Das heißt, da musst du dir wirklich, da musst du dir wirklich Mühe geben und ähm natürlich ist so ein so ein Angriff eben sehr viel anders als ähm.
Da gelten halt so ganz andere Regeln, so. Ich also es auf jeden Fall wird es spannend und ich fand's,
erstmal so niedlich, wie das dann in Deutschland so, ne, Pressemitteilung, Kommando, strategische Aufklärung, Grundausbildung äh äh
Grundfertigkeiten zum Angriff ja, während andere Länder einfach, was weiß ich, China und so, die hacken einfach seit seit Jahren einfach rum und und sehen zu, dass sie Sachen hinkriegen und sind nicht an solche äh äh Strukturen gebunden,
Parlamentsvorbehalt. Also wird spannend. Ich bin mal gespannt, wie das mit deutscher Gründlichkeit dann noch ausdiskutiert wird dieses Thema. Ähm.
Unsere Vorratsdatenspeicherung.
Ja, ja, ja, ja, ja.
Never Ending Thema.
Genau, da habe ich jetzt also äh,
nur nur eine kleine Meldung und zwar ähm die EU-Kommission hat jetzt ihre Pressemitteilung rausgegeben, dass sie also ähm,
Deutschland jetzt da gegen Deutschland diese Klage anstrengt,
Gibt's jetzt eine Zahl und zwar wollen die gerne für jeden Tag,
dem zu erwartenden Urteil, dann ein Zwangsgeld von äh dreihundertfünfzehntausendsechsunddreißig Euro und vierundfünfzig Cent.
Hm. Guten Tag. So ein Schnäppchen.
Das ist also das, worauf sie jetzt, das ist jetzt quasi erstmal der der.
Vorlage, die sie da jetzt gestellt haben. Zwangsgeld, ja, weil wir hatten ja da schon mal drüber berichtet mit Pausch, Betrag und Zwangsgeld und ab wann und so weiter. Also das ist jetzt die die Hausnummer, die da jetzt äh erstmal im Raume steht. Ähm,
Vom Urteil sind wir natürlich weit entfernt. Und jetzt.
Etwas anderes, was wir erwähnt hatten, war ja, dass das gleichzeitig äh Digital Rides Irland
Irgendwann vor dem mit dieser äh äh Verfassungsbeschwerde gegen die Vorratsdatenspeicherung und dass der
irische Heiko, das irgendwie an den EuGH geschoben hätte. Und wir haben ja immer berichtet, dass es äh dass dieses Verfahren eben noch anhängig ist. Und jetzt hat
der von den EuGH geschrieben, hat gefragt wie sieht's da eigentlich aus? Was ist mit diesem Verfahren? Und bekam die Antwort, ähm,
Sehr geehrter Herr, ein derartiges Verfahren ist derzeit nicht anhängig. Ja, also jetzt könnte heißen, dass das,
seit Jahren irgendwie ein äh Unsinn ist, den alle zitieren, dass da irischen Heilkraut äh dieses Verfahren anhängig wäre. Es könnte auch heißen, dass äh wer auch immer dem Herrn
dem Christopher Chakra geantwortet hat, äh das nicht wusste, ja, wie sich mit der aktuellen Lage nicht auseinandergesetzt hat, aber auf jeden Fall mal eine sehr interessante ähm,
Erfahrung in der Hinsicht. Ähm.
Das heißt, das wirkt jetzt auf jeden Fall nicht verzögernd und äh.
Ja, das wirkt genau, diese verzögernde Wirkung ist erstmal nicht da. Also ähm.
Gibt's da noch eine andere verzögernde Wirkung?
Na ja, eventuell halt, dass sie in eventuell na ja, zahlen muss Deutschland eh erst, wenn da ein Urteil ist. Eventuell halt diese Revision der Richtlinie, die ja noch aussteht. Wie, wie es damit aussieht, ist mir halt auch jetzt irgendwie nicht ganz klar.
Nicht ganz klar. Ja, na ja, also macht nicht so den Eindruck, als ob die Sache äh äh wirklich in Wallung kommt, solange unsere aktuelle Regierung noch im Amt ist.
Also müssen wir mal sehen. Na ja okay, also dieses Verfahren läuft jetzt erst mal. Dann gibt's ja noch andere Verfahren, nämlich Österreich ähm,
Wurde jetzt das Verfahren eingestellt, also Österreich wurde das ja auch angedroht und da Österreich in Österreich jetzt grade alle Pläne zur Umsetzung der Vorratsdatenspeicherung bestehen, wurde jetzt halt gerade das Verfahren eingestellt,
Zum Stand in Österreich haben wir in hoffentlich nächste Woche den Thomas nochmal hier,
Thomas Lohninger, die haben ja ähm ja, ich nehme da jetzt mal gar nichts vorweg, ähm Österreich nächste Woche, also Verfahren gegen Österreich eingestellt und bei Schweden ähm,
hatte der die EU EU-Kommission irgendwie einen Pauschalbetrag unten zwangsgeld äh,
angefordert, bei diesem Verfahren und bleiben jetzt nur noch an der an der Pauschalbetragforderung,
halten nur noch daran fest. Also unklare Lage, was da diese ganzen, was da diese ganzen äh Zwangsgelder und so weiter betrifft. Aber für Deutschland haben wir jetzt erstmal einen Geldbetrag da stehen.
Und solange, wie wir, wie dieses Verfahren oder die das Urteil sich hinauszögert, äh wird da auch nichts zu zahlen sein, ne. Wenn wir also sehen, immerhin.
Naja, angeblich boomt ja die Wirtschaft, dann können wir uns das ja auch leisten.
Ja, man kann das ja immer ausrechnen, was das denn irgendwie pro Tag und pro Bürger ist oder so. Ähm, müsste man halt mal gucken.
So, dann ist äh jetzt am Wochenende mal wieder ein bisschen Acta-Action angesagt, ne, wenn ich das richtig sehe.
Neunter sechster ist der große Akt der Aktionstag,
hatte ich ja auch letzte Mal schon die Linkliste verlinkt in welcher Stadt, wo und wann. Aktueller Stand ist, dass ja dass es in durch diese ganzen Ausschüsse die Ausschüsse stimmen quasi ab
und bisher hat der,
der Industrieausschuss der Juri der Rechtsausschuss, der Liebe, der Bürgerrechtsausschuss und der Dawe, der Entwicklungsausschuss,
abgestimmt und davor war's immer so, dass die ähm Konservativen irgendwie diese diese Abstimmung verschieben wollten,
um noch einige Änderungsanträge abzuwarten. Damit sind sie immer nicht durchgekommen und dann gab's eine ablehnende Abstimmung. In vierzehn Tagen ist das dann im internationalen Handelsausschuss, dem Inter. Ähm,
Aber all diese äh diese Entscheidungen der Ausschüsse sind immer nicht verbindlich.
Die entscheidende äh Abstimmung ist Anfang Juli im Plenum. Aber im Moment sieht's also, wie gesagt, ganz gut aus, die ganzen Ausschüsse sind schon mal,
Offensichtlich erstmal auf Linie und das scheint wohl auch so weiterzugehen. Ähm aber Anfang Juli Entscheidende Abstimmung,
im Plenum, auf die muss abgewartet werden und deshalb jetzt am neunten sechsten, der große Akte-Aktionstag mit ähm.
Viel Demonstranten, ja. In Berlin äh zwölf Uhr an der Oberbaumbrücke geht's los.
Da wird äh dann geht's irgendwie so durch durch den Friedrichshainer Kiez irgendwie äh Richtung Alexanderplatz.
Haben wir einen Link für alle Demos.
Haben wir, haben wir, haben wir. Machen wir, machen wir unten dran gleich, ja.
Wir haben getan, wir tun.
Das wird sicherlich nochmal ganz äh ganz nett.
Unter Stopacta DE ist das so der Hauptanlaufpunkt, ja, ne?
Die Übersicht aller Demos.
Der Städte. Ich schaue grad mal wo hier bei was äh ist. Oh ja äh vielseitig. Kann ich das mal nennen? Äh das ein sei eine unvollständige äh Liste heißt es hier noch, was mich ja ein bisschen wundert,
aber wer wohnt in,
Äh also es gibt hier Ahlen Allgäu, nicht wirklich eine Stadt, aber Region, allen Allgäu, Augsburg, Aurich, Bamberg, Berlin, Bremen, Bremerhaven, Dresden, Essen, Frankfurt am Main,
Freiburg, Greifswald, Hamburg, Hannover, Heidelberg, Karlsruhe,
Kassel, Köln, Leer, Magdeburg, Mannheim, Mecklenburg, München, Neubrandenburg, Nürnberg, Ravensburg, Regensburg, Rostock, Saarbrücken, Solingen, Stuttgart, Trier und Würzburg,
schön mit Facebook-Links dazu.
Aachen war nicht dabei?
Nö, ich glaube achten klingt sich dann sicherlich in Köln ein, oder?
So
Keine Ahnung. Na gut, das ist das, was hier steht äh äh mit dem Hinweis, das sei ja unvollständig. Äh sollte irgendjemand da was vermissen, denke ich mal, könnte man sich da auch entsprechend eintragen lassen.
Aber hier ist kein Aachen, nur Aalen.
Also, ja, wird sicherlich äh ganz nett, denke ich mal. Also, hoffen, hoffentlich.
Mit viel Zeug.
Hoffen, ja, gehe ich von aus, ähm es.
Ob's auch Ponies geben wird auf der Demo gegen.
Ich denke, spätestens jetzt wird's.
Was wir bei der Gelegenheit noch so als als ähm interessanter ähm,
Anekdote einfällt, ist das ja von digitale Gesellschaft dieses ganz, also sehr viel Anti-Akter-Material ähm produziert wurde eben mit dem gespendeten Geld. Und das auch ähm
jetzt deutschlandweit in irgendwie riesigen Paketen äh durch die durch die Welt geschickt wird. Ich habe da äh nur immer von gelesen, also ich habe mich da jetzt nicht persönlich dran beteiligt. Aber da wurde äh wohl eine enorme Arbeit geleistet. Da sind alle sehr, sehr äh gibt's also sehr, sehr viel Material.
Und wenn ich das jetzt richtig verstanden habe, scheint das bisher ähm eine der größten,
netzpolitischen Kampagnen so zu sein, also zumindest vom Ausmaß der der Materialien, die dafür geschaffen wurden.
Ja irgendwie jute Boy äh und und Aufkleber und Flyer und äh Info äh hier und Faltblatt da. Also ein sehr, sehr umfangreiches Material, was da geschaffen wurde für viele tausend Euro
die jetzt also was jetzt auch irgendwie durch ganz Deutschland irgendwie verschifft wird und bei allen Demos dann verteilt wird. Fand ich mal ganz ähm.
Ganz interessant, dass es also es scheint echt so das Größte das Größte bisher zu sein. Und das wiederum zeigt, dass das ähm.
Es ist ja eigentlich noch nicht so groß, ja. Also da könnte halt noch der könnte und müsste eventuell bei anderen Themen noch sehr, sehr viel mehr gehen. Also ich habe da so die Vorratsdatenspeicherung jetzt äh durchaus nochmal als Thema, was ich irgendwann in nächster Zeit dann,
auf die Agenda kommt, der,
Hängt ja jetzt hauptsächlich vom äh EuGH ab. Wenn der sagt, okay, das behandeln wir jetzt mal relativ flott, dieses Thema, dann kann das halt auch ähm.
Was weiß ich, innerhalb eines Jahres oder so hier wieder äh ein großes Thema sein. Und bei solchen ähm also bei solchen Kampagnen muss halt,
als eine als eine Perspektive nehmen, aber da muss halt muss halt noch mehr kommen, ja.
Mehr Butter bei Fische noch.
Nicht nur jetzt nicht nur von digitaler Gesellschaft aus, sondern natürlich auch von von allen, aber also Akte ist ja jetzt schon eine sehr große, sehr große Sache, die da so läuft. Ähm,
und ähm diejenigen, die das da jetzt gemacht haben, weil die gegessen haben da auch äh denke ich eine sehr coole Arbeit gemacht, wenn sie sind, sehen auch ganz cool designed aus, wir können das ja nochmal verlinken diese Materialien
Ansonsten, wenn jetzt zu den Demos geht, sind die, ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit groß, dass ihr ohnehin irgendwelches von diesen Material in die Finger gedrückt bekommt,
Und dann wollen wir mal schauen, wie viel ähm wie viel Wind es dann nochmal gelingt, zu erzeugen.
Genau und darüber werden wir dann alles nächste Woche berichten. Vielleicht mit Thomas, auch aus Österreich, mal so ein bisschen hier die Stimmung zusammentragen und äh.
Er hat sich angekündigt, Thomas, jetzt musst du liefern. Ich weiß genau, dass du uns hörst.
Genau, fang schon mal an, dich vorzubereiten. Haben wir's.
Ja, gibt's dazu irgendwas? Ich weiß nicht, was machst du heute Nachmittag? Nee, nee, wir sind fertig.
Genau, das war's. Logbuchnetzpolitik, siebenundzwanzigster Ausgabe. Äh vielen Dank fürs Zuhören. Bis bald. Bis dahin, tschau, tschau.
Bis dahin, tschau, tschau.